[music]
I can't let you go I can't let you
go I
'm desperate for that  It's just a matter of who's going
to hit their fist first What's
the
matter?
No wonder why you think so
This is not my arm My Sticky Fingers ability can connect things
with zippers  But what will happen
to me?
Kill the old man's irrelevant things like trash If he's the guy, he must be defeated
[music]
beware
old exterior
Only your senses are certain sushi
I can say all the movements slowly
There's one
thing I'm starting to understand
It's
like a place where I'm in love I
'm not
going
Where are you?  It's too good
[music]
Defensive
Chief Lacaju is going in two I
'm playing Municipal Kamanai is
n't aiming for that isn't
it?
I thought,
Climbing the multi-arms to reach the heart is
a safe way to
go to the heart  Don't put it on, I'll be
exposed all the time ana
[music]
Hm, I'll say it after I'm done saying that I'll kill you.
The movie that puts me out pb is this bastard Is it fate that I
learned anyway from your ability to gouge out your head and turn the world into parts
Or is it the attraction between similar stands  So it was
you and me Thanks to you my gold experience just grew
Where did
it go I just blew it away Where did your wrist
blew it
away  If you serve China, you'd better use your hands to protect yourself rather than attack me Don't throw them away,
yeah  It's a
piranha that you know is going in. It's
dangerous and I'm begging you to say it.
[Music]
That's
tough.
amaran
[music] yeah yeah yeah [music]
there's still consciousness in this one
Shoot it with Mara
If it doesn't
move, it responds to the movement of the hands and preferentially attacks the clock over and over again
.
Speed ​​is murder
However,
the power like a vise is a daughter 3
teru This guy is chopped into small pieces
[music]
me
a good piano right
away  Hey,
you guys, nasty baboons, what you're going to wear from now on is a good name I
see, running towards you is a short-range power-type bag
, 3 meters from the car theme.
The day I didn't have it a
me
Hey, hey, I like to take it out
Today's God
side has to get your ass to get the money
What are you doing?
If I can get out of this village by car, that's fine.
I
guess I didn't know
where I was ha
[music]